[Music]
[Applause]
otto
bolden was there watch dk metcalf the
seattle
seahawks wide receiver and ran a 10-3
auto kind enough to join us uh what did
you expect from dk metcalf otto
it changed over time um when i saw the
play initially
um i i think i irked a lot of football
fans by saying okay
big deal 10-4 guy runs down 10-6 guy and
america goes crazy fastest guy on the
planet
and then i started listening to people
who i thought knew more than me like
renato nian maya for example and you
know he was a football
player and he obviously had a world
record in the hurdles and he said oh you
know
dk's going to get this shirt and i was
like why am i giving dk too much credit
so by the time we went on the air i said
well i don't know 10 6 10
7. if you told me this guy was going to
run 10-3 i'd have said
no way but but he did and uh and i think
he you know even though he crosses the
line in last he
he was the winner yesterday well also
i'm looking at his form
out of the blocks like this is what you
did for a living for a long time and
and you analyzed this for a living so if
you're looking at his form
what could you correct and what do you
think is actually possible for dk
metcalf
i didn't see a lot wrong with his form i
i said when i analyzed the the start in
real time i said
if you look at this video you wouldn't
be able to tell oh yeah there's the nfl
wide receiver he looked like a sprinter
for most of the race one of the things
that i said before the gun went
off is my concern is that weight that he
carries to be an
fly receiver to have an nfl body is
going to show up at some point during
the race well it probably showed up at
about 80 and when everybody started to
decelerate as all sprinters do towards
the end of the race
he was decelerating a lot more than
everybody else he probably could have
hung on for maybe sixth or seventh
but um no his his form i wouldn't change
a lot other than he didn't he didn't
relax probably as
well as a sprinter knows to relax
because they know the fatigue is going
to come but no
form wise he was fine i remember carl
lewis telling me this a couple of years
ago he said he knew that it was i think
44 steps
is that strides does that sound right
yeah for carl he'd probably take uh 44
or maybe even furious
okay uh and what did usain bolt take
uh usain was 42 and a half
and what did you use how many strides
i was 45 46 on a on a bad day
what was your single best time 9.86
read it four times what is that feeling
like
you know what before i ran something i
had a teammate who had run
john drummond would run 9.9 he was like
yeah you know it's like you step into
this whole dimension
and you come on the other side and
you're like oh my gosh you've run under
10 seconds now mind you
when i ran under 10 i was like the
eighth or ninth guy to do it
the first time i ran uh the first time i
ran under 10 seconds which oh by the way
was at the mountain relays where dk ran
yesterday
it felt like 1005 or 10 10
and he said oh you ran 993 and i went oh
that's it oh great
so it doesn't it doesn't feel any
different to you know okay any other
good performance you know you've run
fast but there's no like you know
there's no sound barrier to go through i
got you as one of the
top 15 top 15 people have
walked this earth who have
run this fast that's pretty cool
i think i'm in the top 50. i mean you
know look you know
you can't compare errors it's like
trying to compare you know guys who used
to shoot the three well to what you know
what we see now in the nba um i think
i'm i'm i'm up there still but
um i think my i think my skill was being
able to run
both the 100 and the 200 pretty well
paulie what what do you have uh otto
what what what's his time i got 986
but there's only i got 13 humans have
ever run 986 or
lower oh wow so dan you're right i'm
still in the top 15.
maybe you should take my job at that at
nbc because i i certainly should have
known that i didn't think i was in the
top 15.
i thought maybe top 20. if dk metcalf
called you and said
give me some advice and do you think i
could actually do this
and make the olympic team in four years
oh i think i think he he'd have a shot
the first thing is that he'd have to be
closer to 200 pounds
than 235 and you notice when uh lewis
johnson asked him yesterday so you know
are you going to train more like she's
like yo i got mini camp
he knows he knows who cuts the checks
in his life but yes if he called me and
said in four years
um i think he'd have a legitimate shot
because i i think he i mean obviously
he's a freak of an athlete
because to carry that weight for
that far and run 1036 having trained for
what four or five months i think is is
so
amazing um he'd have to lose a lot of
weight and he'd have to really train
hard but he certainly he has the chops
no question
would you rather be usain bolt or tom
brady
have their careers oh wow
i mean obviously my track and field bias
is going to show
you know what they're both pretty equal
because both of them have one thing in
common
i don't think anybody is going to doubt
that they are the greatest of
all time in their sport and certainly in
sports period so um yeah probably
probably both
but i i think with bolt somebody
eventually comes along and will be
faster than him
i don't know when but somebody will it's
gonna be really hard for somebody to
come along and win
seven super bowls so i i i would rather
be tom brady
but i will say if if usain bolt was at a
cocktail party and so was tom brady
i'm probably more curious about usain
bolt in some of the things
that i could ask him well i would
counter that then by saying
that it is go you know every bit
sprinting is not
mapped so you see guys running like nine
eight or nine seven you go well that's
that's not too far off the record
i am saying to you that's the gap but
the gap between what they're running
now and 958 and 1919 which are both
world records
and the gap between whoever has i don't
know four or
three super bowl rings and brady is
about the same so don't
don't think that that both world records
are going anywhere anytime soon it's
gonna be a long time before somebody
gets there trust me
is there trash talking in sprinting
there used to be in my era this is the
kumbaya generation
they don't they don't actually like each
other but they pretend they do
because it's the politically correct era
um i have to say
you know about you know getting back to
dk i
looked yesterday and all weekend for any
sign of like
superiority like he didn't walk into
this track meet like
yeah i'm the big pro bowl wide receiver
and you guys are near sprinters this guy
was humble he you know he tried to
assimilate
he didn't he didn't even leave after his
he stayed and watched the entire meeting
i went
my god i'm a 49er fan since i was
born it's against my religion to like a
seahawk but i'm gonna follow this guy
because i think
i think he's a real i think he's a
fantastic kid
are you are you a niners fan i am a
niners fan grew up watching montana to
rice and
clark and everybody yes ronnie lot the
whole deal
did you try to play football
you know what when i moved here at 14
my high school jamaica high school which
produced some guy named bob beeman
um did not have a football team so i
think at the time when i should have
like maybe been pulled in that direction
i didn't have anywhere to go and i
stayed in soccer and then eventually
went the track
if if we ran the 100 meter today what
would you run
yeah uh probably like 11
110 110 yeah
so we're about even oh yeah
[Laughter]
it's great to catch up with you again
otto uh we appreciate your time thank
you hope you
have a great summer you too guys always
good to be on with you
that's uh otto bolden nbc sports lead
track analyst olympic analyst and uh
one of the top 15 times
100 meter dash times in the history of
the world